[music playing]
WIL WILLIS: David,
Jordan, congratulations.
You've made it into the third
round of this competition.
Good job.
If you thought the last
six hours was tough,
it's nothing compared
to the next five days
because we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history.
And that weapon is--
the Talwar pommel.
[music playing]
JORDAN: I could comfortably make
a blade like this in a week.
And I can uncomfortably
make one in five days.
WIL WILLIS: After five
days, you will return
and present your
finished Talwars
to our panel of expert judges.
Only after they've put
them through a series
of brutal tests will
they declare one of you
the "Forged in Fire"
champion who also walks away
with that check for 10 grand.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
[music playing]
DAVID: It's day one.
We're at my home forge
in Kalkaska, Michigan.
Hopefully, today I can
get my blade rough forged.
That-- that's the plan anyway.
[music playing]
I've never done a sword of
this magnitude, of difficulty.
So we'll see how it turns out.
I just got to make it perfect
because my competitor is
really good.
[music playing]
So day one, I'd like to be
a little further, of course.
But all in all, it's
been a good day.
[music playing]
JORDAN: It's day two.
I'm trying to get
this blade a little
longer to fit the parameters.
I'm getting a little worried.
This fuller is
buckled right here.
When the fuller
starts to buckle,
it means that the-- the wall
on either side is really thin,
and it's starting
to move around.
And there's a danger of
grinding through when
you go to the grinder.
So I'm gonna start
this blade over.
[music playing]
Back to working on the fuller.
I'm a little behind
where I hoped I'd be.
And I'm exhausted.
Finally.
If you want to call that good.
DAVID: All right, day four.
The blade is done.
Now, it's time for the handle.
I've never made an
entirely metal handle.
A handle is a tricky
piece of forge work.
So I'm a little nervous.
This is as hard as I expected.
[music playing]
It's cracking like crazy.
I'm seeing all these
cracks in my handle.
And I don't have
any way to fix them.
I'm starting over.
Restarting the handle puts
me about five hours behind.
It's going to be crunch time.
I'm ready to be done
with this handle.
I was determined
not to screw it up.
And here I am,
screwing it up again.
[music playing]
JORDAN: Day five, I
had this crazy idea
of doing a Damascus handle.
But the Damascus that
I made was too hard.
So we're going with plan B,
which is the hollow form pipe.
I don't know why I didn't
think of this sooner.
[music playing]
The advantage of
this was no drilling.
It's pretty much ready to go.
And so now, we're actually
going to get the blade polished,
get the handle welded up,
get it epoxied to the blade.
I'm feeling relieved.
And then chop some stuff.
[music playing]
There we go.
That makes me happy.
Nice.
J NEILSON: All right, gentlemen.
This is the sharpness test.
Now, the Talwar was a blade
respected throughout India.
So to test the
sharpness of your blade,
I'll be cutting
into the sugarcanes.
David, you're up.
You ready?
Absolutely.
J NEILSON: All right.
[music playing]
DAVID: I-- I know
my weapon is sharp.
But there's always that
little bit of doubt.
[music playing]
J NEILSON: Looks like the
sugarcane speaks for itself.
There's a lot of weight in this.
But it's not bad.
It's balanced very well.
So the design of
your knuckle bow
being inside where
this-- this pommel
is, if my hand slips back there,
I'm kind of whacking into that.
But it's sharp.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
All right, Jordan.
You ready?
I'm ready.
OK, let's do this.
[music playing]
I just love sabers.
This is a cutter.
It's fast.
It's light.
But the profile of your handle
could be a little bit larger
for my hand.
But all in all, the cuts
speak for themselves.
It just passed through with
no resistance whatsoever.
Nicely done.
DAVID: Our blades, they're
performing almost identical.
This is going to be tight.
The Talwar, a
battle-tested weapon.
But what kind of lethal
damage does this weapon do?
To find that out, I
will take your weapon
and deliver killing blows
on this ballistics dummy.
David, you're up first.
You ready?
Oh, yeah.
Let's do this.
DAVID: Doug and the
ballistics dummy, this
is the test that
I wanted to see.
I'm just, like, super excited.
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA: Your
edge of your blade
is sharp enough to
cut and lacerate
the whole torso here, cutting
deep and cutting into bone.
Same thing with the clavicle
over here and into the ribs.
Your handle construction is a
little bit on the wider side.
But it's wieldable.
Overall, your weapon will kill.
Good job.
Thank you.
Jordan, you're next.
You ready?
I'm ready.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Jordan.
Let's talk about your blade.
Your edge geometry here
definitely lends itself
to be a very good thruster.
It's sliced in easily.
Your edge is razor sharp.
But I'm able to lacerate into
the dummy and break some bones.
Your handle, it's a little
bit on the skinny side.
But I'm still able to
index and hold onto it.
Your weapon will kill.
JORDAN: After this
round, it feels like 2-2.
Dave and I still
feel really even.
All right, gentlemen,
this is the strength test.
The Talwar was a battle-tested
weapon known to actually
take heads in combat.
To test the strength and
durability of your blades,
I'll be chopping four times
into these beef rib sides.
This is not about what your
blade does to the beef,
but what these ribs
do to your blades.
All right, David, you're up.
You ready?
Ready as I'll ever be.
A side of beef is
extremely tough.
It can potentially break
a blade, or chip a blade,
or bend a blade.
So I'm concerned.
[music playing]
Wow.
J NEILSON: OK, David,
I've got a little bit
of chipping and rolling
right where the impact is.
It's not deep.
But it is there.
All in all, it felt good.
All right, Jordan, you ready?
I guess so.
I'm pretty nervous.
You know, getting through the
bone is going to be tricky.
And all I can think
is, please don't chip.
Please don't chip.
[music playing]
Took a little
shrapnel off that one.
I can run my fingernail
along that edge
and not feel anything.
No bumps, no chips,
still straight.
Everything's still tight.
Good job.
Thank you.
I'm breathing a
huge sigh of relief.
But I know that also my
handle is a little small.
And people have been sent
home for handles before.
[music playing]
WIL WILLIS: David,
Jordan, both of you
have made excellent blades.
And you've been
fantastic competitors.
But in this arena
of competition,
there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Before I announce who
that is, the judges have
some feedback for both of you.
J NEILSON: Dave, you
brought us a weapon
that was a pleasure to use.
It's a heavy weapon.
But you balanced
it out beautifully.
Nice job.
Thank you.
WIL WILLIS: Doug?
Jordan, the artistry
of your handle
is matched by the
beauty, strength,
and sharpness of your blade.
Well done, sir.
WIL WILLIS: Gentlemen,
when weapons
of this caliber come into
this arena, these decisions
are never easy.
The "Forged in Fire"
champion is Jordan.
Congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Congratulations.
J NEILSON: David, you
created a beautiful weapon.
And it was a pleasure to use it.
And this decision came down to
the finest details, basically
the positioning of that
knuckle bow on the handle
and those chips that
turned up in your blade
in the strength test.
For those two reasons,
we're letting you go.
WIL WILLIS: David, please
surrender your weapon.
[music playing]
DAVID: Absolutely no regrets.
I would have liked
to have done better.
But I agree with the
judge's decision.
I came here to
prove that I could
hang with some of
the best bladesmiths
in the United States.
And I think I proved
that I can do that.
Jordan, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
that check for $10,000.
How do you feel right now?
I feel great.
And I feel pretty accomplished.
Well, you should.
JORDAN: What a great way
to jump start my career,
you know, making really
high quality blades.
Well done.
JORDAN: This is what I really
wanted for a long time.
That's why I came here.
Thank you.
I'm "Forged in Fire" champion.
[music playing]